اذا ترسانه النوويه قادره على تدمير
العالم مرات عده مع مخزون يتضمن اكثر من
5500 راسا حربيا حقائق مخيفه اصلا زادها
رعبا تدشين روسيا منشئه لتخزين الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه هنا في بيلاروسيا على
الجبهه الشماليه تحديدا الغربيه من روسيا
لكن من الممسك والمتحكم باكبر مخزون في
العالم من الرؤوس النوويه بالتاكيد هو
بوتين صانع القرار النهائي الذي يحمل بين
يديه ما يسمى بالحقيبه النوويه في كل
الاوقات هناك حقيبتان متشابهتان يعتقد
بانهما بحوزه وزير الدفاع الحالي
ورئيس الاركان العامه الحالي جيراسيموف
هذه الحقيقه او الحقيبه النوويه تشكل اداه
اتصال تربط بوتين بكبار ضباطه العسكريين
ومن ثم طبعا بالقوات الصاروخيه عبر شبكه
القياده والتحكم الالكترونيه الشديده
السريه كما هو معلوم غير ان بوتين بامكانه
تنشيط ما يسمى بنظام اليد الميته كملاذ
اخير وهي اجهزه الكمبيوتر التي تقرر ما
يسمى بيوم القيامه ان شعر بهجوم النووي
استراتيجي يواجه حينها ويرسل عبر هذه
الحقائب امر باطلاق مباشر الى قياده
الاركان العامه وطبعا وحدات القياده
الاحتياطيه التي تحمل رموزا نوويه لهذا
الاطلاق بعدها تتسلسل الاوامر بسرعه الى
انظمه الاتصالات المختلفه ووحدات القوه
الصاروخيه الاستراتيجيه لتطلق بعد ذلك على
الاعداء او المهاجمين المفترضين
[موسيقى]